well it's a pleasure to be with all of
you today part of the reason why I call
Tina my Stanford mom is her son his name
Josh as well so there's that commonality
in place but it was 10 years ago I
actually was running ETL so this was a
seminar that I used to manage as a part
of basis I think I still might hold a
record I took this class 14 quarters in
a row so if anyone's close to beating
that please let me know as well but the
main goal of this topic of this chat is
going to be kind of walking through a
couple of different chapters in my life
discussing some entrepreneurial stories
trying to share some lessons with all of
you and then hoping to have some good
Q&A afterwards as well so these are the
three chapters we're going to be
covering we're gonna be starting with
kind of where it all begins kind of
upbringing and college days as well
we'll be talking about my prior to
startup endeavors and then kind of
wrapping up with deep dive into
zenpayroll but with a really strong
emphasis on the why not just the how
kind of the motivation to start a
business the values that drive it and
then the mission what is a mission mean
when you talk about startups so in terms
of growing up kind of happy to share
with you and one of the few locals I was
actually born in San Francisco I grew up
in Marin County which if you haven't
been there is great for hiking and my
parents are actually both teachers my
mom's from Bolivia she came to the US
when she was 18 my dad's from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania and they're both the first
in their families to go to college and
so they taught mostly humanities English
history social studies so I didn't have
too much personal exposure to technology
growing up but I was always curious
about how things worked and and frankly
to me the entrepreneurial journey that
my parents were on to move to a whole
new country or a city or state isn't in
of itself its own story of wanting to
make the most of an opportunity so the
common thread I do see though which I'll
come back to is that curiosity and then
always being very bothered by
inefficiency which is we get to this
imperil conversation you'll get a tip of
the hat on kind of why that's a relevant
part of our mission for the business but
kind of bring it all back to Stanford
again when I was here this
buildings than even exist we used to
have these seminars in terminada torreón
which was a beautiful building just that
way which is now a lovely fountain
without any building there anymore at
all
but when I came with Stanford it was
2001 the bubble had just burst there was
actually from 2001 to 2003 40% decline
in enrollment in the CS major right if
you think about that it's kind of
inverse to what's happening these days
but I was really excited to study
Electrical Engineering for me EE was
about really understanding complex
systems and I love the mathematical
aspect to it and I get asked a lot these
days you know was EE helpful is EE
relevant to what I'm doing today and I
think we're going to talk about that in
a bit kind of how academics tired of
what you do in a work environment but
the answer is absolutely now I'm not
using Fourier transforms in my
day-to-day job obviously but the ability
to understand complex systems and take
these really really complex problems and
simplify them to a couple key things
that matter whether it's in hiring or
whether it's in making a business
strategy decision whether it's in
selling a product developing software or
even in other things like politics or
economic development I really think that
again that mindset is what's most
valuable versus the actual coursework
that you're going through so kind of to
share a couple of thoughts on college
again all of you are at Stanford or at
least a part of the Stanford community
that's incredible this is an amazing
institution I always tell folks if I
could buy stock in a university I would
buy stock in Stanford because it's
incredible to see what the university
has done over the last 10 20 30 years in
terms of really driving change in the
world but I think that that question
that was asked earlier again a lot of
students ask me what what should I study
to go do this what should I study to go
achieve this goal and I think to me the
real heart and soul of college is really
about discovering who you are
discovering what you care about
understanding the things that interest
you and that requires experimentation I
mean when I was at Stanford I worked in
three different labs during my time in
undergrad I worked at four different
internships each summer different
experience different industry different
area to
deep-dive learn when I was at Intel my
freshman summer I emailed the entire
executive team at Intel down in Santa
Clara and I said hey do you have 15-20
minutes to grab coffee would love to
just talk I'm a freshman in Turnitin
tell we left to get a sense of you know
what what you do and also why you why
you do what you do and I met with like
half the executive team and I member at
one point I'm talking with one of my
colleagues who was a PhD graduate and he
was wondering why I was meeting with his
boss's boss's boss's boss and I just
said I emailed him right it wasn't that
hard it was simply the act of putting
out that that risk of hey fear of
rejection but also nothing really bad
happens if someone ignores your email
they don't put you on a blacklist if you
email them a hundred times in a row
maybe but again one piece of advice
there is send that email as a student
you have this almost blank check to
either an email someone in industry
someone in the company are working with
and just ask for some advice and most
folks that have come through your shoes
will want to give back it's kind of the
key to this entire community is the idea
of giving back because we've all
benefited from it tremendously but the
key thing I also wanted to emphasize
there around school is that there there
is no right or wrong answer I think a
lot of times again students are looking
for the right path the key path to go
achieve a specific goal up until you
won't go to Stanford it's pretty clear
get good grades go to a good school
afterwards there is no clear path it's
really what you want to make of it so
make sure you explore but to shift into
chapter two this was right when I was
graduating I was Mayfield fellow as Tina
mentioned my internship was at a company
named Zazzle I was either gonna do a PhD
in neural prosthetics which is a really
interesting topic if you guys have any
questions about it or I was gonna go
join a software startup and what I
concluded was what I really wanted to do
was be involved in solving a problem and
to end where I could be understanding
the customer need developing the
solution iterating developing improving
it and then you know obviously bringing
it to that customer and continuing that
cycle and so that's why I joined Zazzle
full-time I was a product manager which
is an amazing job for someone right out
of school gives you a chance to
really understand prioritization but
also again you're kind of responsible
for a road map responsible for something
being done we're not actually a manager
of anyone so the ability is to influence
and inspire without being able to say do
this because I told you so is actually a
really really useful skill to have but
what I loved about the mission is Zazzle
if you're not familiar is it was a way
for people all over the world to go
build products digital products and then
whenever someone else bite it or bought
it those products would be manufactured
and shipped out so for me as a p.m. it
was a chance to go enable people all
over the world and make a living doing
things they loved right designing
awesome products expressing their
creativity and this is actually a photo
of Alejandro he's a artist in Uruguay
who literally makes tens of thousands of
dollars a year by just uploading his
paintings through the website at an
internet cafe near his house so I guess
the main advice I have there on kind of
choosing where to go when you graduate
is really think about who you want to
become like I think again Stanford
students is easy to kind of want to
build frameworks and spreadsheets and
come up with any other 20 different
optimizations on you know growth rate
and funding amounts and all these
different ways to determine which
company you should join one way to
simplify it is just to think about who
would you like to become like because
you become like the people you spend
time with whether you want to or not
and so you know choose wisely would be
the main piece of advice there another
topic related to school that I really am
passionate about this is just one
framework as many frameworks but in my
opinion there really is two main types
of learning there is academic learning
and then there is kind of tactical
learning and academic learning is a
chance to learn purely for the sake of
curiosity right it's why many of you are
here in school today it's a chance to go
discover try different things you're
interested in the subject figure it out
and and it's amazing it's a huge part of
my foundation what everyone has to make
a choice at some point on how much of
their life should be spent doing
academic learning versus tactical
learning and tactical learning happens
just as much in a start-up it's learning
whatever you need to learn to overcome
whatever obstacles in front of you and
then you move forward again to the next
obstacle so it's a different type of
learning
for me that was big part of why I left
the ph.d program was my desire to have
that kind of 90/10 split on academic for
his tactical learning shift to kind of a
1090 split and today even now it's
really awesome to spend some time on
campus speak with different professors
you know you only think you ever want to
have that go to zero but the chance to
still have that curiosity be explored
and whatever discipline you're focused
on is really important otherwise you can
get caught up in its act achill piece
every day and then that can help you get
burned down so zazzle I grew very
quickly I was there from about 20
employees to about 150 and then in 2008
as Tina mentioned I started a company
with a colleague of mine actually a
friend who had gone to Stanford with but
he had been at Google for four years and
the way I would summarize this startup
experience it was a two-year chapter in
my life was that it was very reactive
you know to kind of be very open and
transparent with you again there's many
reasons to start a company many ways to
build a business this was right when
Facebook platform launched in 2008 and I
had just been finishing up my Master's I
was working full time and doing my
school part-time and I took the class at
Stanford called the Facebook class if
you guys have heard about it it kind of
became a pretty infamous class because
of the companies that came out of it but
what happened with this business was we
were making you know thousand two
thousand dollars a day really in our
first month of operating and it was
these platform of applications where
other businesses could go build apps on
Facebook if you didn't have any
technical skill set so there was some
elements of I think mission involved in
terms of enabling these business owners
but it was also just a very reactive
business where we were like hey this is
working let's keep doing it and what
happened was over the ensuing year
year-and-a-half we kept doing well
financially but you really felt like
something was missing it didn't feel
like we knew where we were going over
the next two five ten years and as we
were hiring teammates that bothered me
right if if I didn't feel like this is
something I could spend 10 20 years
working on and speak about thousands and
thousands of times with the same
conviction and passion then it didn't
feel right and so that was why even
though we had offers for funding at that
point we ended up going down the
acquisition
route it was because it didn't a
no-judgment on the space of social media
if you guys are passionate about it you
have to find what's authentic to you but
it just was too fluffy for us and that
was why we went through the acquisition
so you know that kind of leads to a
really important I think message which
is the power of introspection I mean I
went through a period afterwards for a
few months of really trying to
understand what I enjoyed doing in the
previous several years what I wanted to
do different what had worked what hadn't
worked and and this is a message in
general not just related to you know in
between startup chapters I mean I think
one of the beauties of school is you
have these quarter systems right where
basically every in-between every quarter
you have to decide what classes did I
like and what classes didn't out like in
which classes don't want to do different
next quarter and if you can imagine when
you start working those quarters go away
you know you can have 10 years of work
pass by without ever taking a step back
to determine do I like what I'm doing
and a lot of folks that don't take that
time end up being unhappy even though
they're quote-unquote successful
professionally because they haven't
taken the time to really think about is
this what they want to spend their time
doing so my biggest advice here is even
when you graduate set up your own
quarter semester system it could be
weekly monthly quarterly or yearly
whatever cycle you're on this is a photo
of Palo Alto foothills park um I used to
when I lived down here go down there
every Sunday it's just over Page Mill
and it's a gorgeous park but for me
nature is a place to find solace
whatever it is that gives you that place
to think more deeply about what's
working what's not working make sure you
would set aside that time otherwise life
will just pass you by so for me that
introspection led to a pretty extensive
kind of thought process around what had
been missing in my prior startup right
why had I even though it was succeeding
quote-unquote financially why was I
still kind of feeling like there was
something missing and the answer for me
was he didn't feel like a mission you
know when I had started the nonprofit in
college and we were building this
movement around helping students in the
US and China go do social projects
together get to know each other better
try to help other people you know I
would be working till 4:00
five in the morning I'd be recruiting
students we built up all these different
chapters and it didn't feel like work it
just felt like something that I really
believed in and I really cared about and
I was happy to talk to pretty much to
anyone I met and so I kind of went
through this introspective process to
figure out what are the types of
problems I really cared about and this
was the outcome of that it was really
understanding that you know these are
the types of missions that I could get
behind and we're going to influence how
I wanted to spend the rest of my life
and so to go through the three and again
these are just personal to me they can
be very different for you it was number
one businesses that helped someone make
a living doing something they love that
was kind of why I had joined zazzle in
the first place it was incredible to
empower someone to follow their passions
and be able to then live in a in a
capitalistic world with the capital they
need to survive too as businesses that
help someone do something they've always
wanted to do more from an empowerment
standpoint it's one of the you know most
amazing aspects of Technology is the
ability to kind of take things that
previously used to require tons of
equipment or tons of money or tons of
people and now you know literally one
person can do it I mean what's happening
with drones right now for photography
and videography is incredible I have a
lot of friends that are really enjoying
some of those technologies and then the
third was kind of back to my earlier
point on being bothered by inefficiency
you know any kind of product solution
that just brings massive time savings
massive cost savings to the world was
something that I could really get behind
so that kind of leads to the third
chapter which is the creation of
zenpayroll so zenpayroll we started the
company about three years ago and I have
two co-founders we're actually all
electrical engineering from Stanford so
I kind of joke that EE has a lot to do
with payroll software actually our head
of design is also EE our first engineer
was EE my wife is EE actually but
nothing against people that are not EE
what really brought us together before
we kind of dive into like how we built
the business we brought us together
again is is not some mapping of
strategic skillsets or some spreadsheet
optimized on complimentary value add it
was values right to me all of us had had
prior startups we were all at a very
similar
stage in life of wanting to go solve a
problem that we could imagine spending
the rest of our life working on and that
was what glued us together it wasn't
again some logical mapping of skill it
was frankly the three of us connecting
around kind of what we cared about in
life and what we believed in and so
that's one advice I have for folks that
are interested in starting companies
when you're starting especially with who
you choose to partner with and found a
company with a wetters way way more than
then skill or expertise is understanding
that person's motivations understanding
what they stand for and making sure
that's aligned with your motivations
otherwise it's gonna be hard to go build
that business together for the long term
and I think the the way I would
summarize that is again there's there's
many ways to build a company we were
solving a problem by creating a business
we were not interested in creating a
business to go solve a problem and it's
again a very different mindset to kind
of be focused on the problem as your
starting point versus all the logistics
of building a company so in terms of how
did we choose this idea we really had
two catalysts one was we'd all run prior
startup so we'd all kind of been through
that journey we had sold prior companies
to but we had all run payroll so that
was one personal frustration if any of
you have run payroll using historical
legacy systems it's a pretty
time-consuming process and then to
almost a coincidence until you realize
how many people have small businesses in
their family each of us had family that
had run payroll too so Tomer who runs
our products team his father owns a
small clothing store in Haifa Israel and
he had been helping his dad in the back
office since he was a kid Edward who
runs our engineering team his mother
runs payroll for a doctor's office in LA
and then my mother-in-law actually runs
payroll for companies down in Silicon
Valley so those are kind of the two
catalysts and again in terms of the
business types that we were attracted to
I kind of bucket those into two worlds
there's businesses that are out there to
go invent whole new use cases for the
future you know things that have never
existed before and Facebook is a great
example and the biggest puzzle there is
you know will a billion people want this
well two billion people want to use this
but there's also
whole other category of businesses that
are about really just fixing existing
problems improving existing industries
using changes in technology shifts in
society to go kind of redo what has been
done in the past and these are companies
like nest right redoing how thermostats
function companies like square redoing
how point-of-sale systems function you
know the three of us all gravitated
towards this category kind of the
ability to from day one with one
customer know that we were actually
solving a real problem really resonated
with us and again there's many
entrepreneurs that have been successful
in both buckets but try to figure out as
you think about your journey which one
you gravitate towards because it's hard
to move to the other unless it's what
you really believe in so the way we got
started as any any startup should is
talking to customers this is a Christina
Aston Belle she actually started a
company called farm girl flowers in San
Francisco it's actually a really cool
story which you guys should all use for
products it's a great flower service but
we talked a lot of these customers and
we were pretty shocked to learn again it
wasn't just our pain point if you're
building a business just for yourself
you have to figure out how big is the
market how many people actually share
this pain and we were shocked by two
statistics
number one we were shocked by the fact
that of the six million businesses in
the u.s. today about a third of them
every year get fined for incorrectly
doing their payroll taxes and that's
every year about a third of companies
make mistakes and get penalized and then
the second step we're shocked by is that
about 40% of the six million businesses
that need payroll do payroll today by
hand so they do it on spreadsheets they
do it manually Eddie's mother was one
example having done it by hand for
twenty five years and so that was
shocking to us they didn't make any
sense you know it if you look at payroll
it's a set of complex rules fifteen
thousand different tax codes these are
entrepreneurs these are small business
owners that have been wearing 20
different hats trying to figure it all
out on their own and they haven't really
had the benefit of software to help them
because they weren't really a
cost-effective market to go serve and
that's changed right now these folks are
on the Internet they have mobile devices
they use Google to search for new
products to use they're finally an
audience that you can bring us
service two and it was very clear to us
that payroll should not be done by hand
and so we wanted to build a product I
use Gmail as the analogy you know you
don't have to know how SMTP or IMAP or
pop 3 works to send a message to someone
you shouldn't have to know all the
different tax codes and compliance
requirements to go pay someone right to
go build a business which is really a
lot of the foundation of the American
economy and so those are two stats that
shocked us and then I think that the
second thing I'll mention is you know
we've never done payroll before and I
think this is a lesson to for a lot of
folks that sometimes get intimidated by
oh I've never worked in that industry
before how can I solve it how could I do
something better it's actually a huge
strength to not have been in an industry
before as long as you know what you
don't know - right so obviously when it
came to payroll compliance we hired some
folks with 20 years of experience in
taxes and compliance because it has to
be done correctly but when we looked at
payroll you know many of you probably
today when you hear the word payroll
think of it as this chore or this hassle
or don't even know what it really is
until you get paid we thought of it very
differently and for us we thought of it
as having these two building blocks on
the one side it's an employee getting
paid and hopefully all of you are in
this boat - but people love to get paid
I mean every two weeks we sent an email
to tens of thousands of people that says
you got paid today and that comes from
zenpayroll
you can guess what the open rate is of
that email what the click-through rate
of that email is so that seems pretty
magical right we're kind of enabling
this really meaningful part of what it
means to work and on the other side it's
employers you know rewarding their
employees for their hard work it's
helping them feel appreciated for what
they've done and now that was a shocking
realization again for us that seemed
like common sense but that's not how
this industry has worked in the past in
the past payroll has been an ID number
where you get you know set a specific
employee number ID and then you kind of
have a transaction you don't even know
when you get paid it's in your bank
account and for us this seemed very
clear that payroll is actually in
reality more about people than payments
right it's about this relationship
between these two stakeholders so that
was something that really influenced how
we think about the business and you know
one of our investors is drew from
Dropbox they have a very similar story
where their first hundred employees
no one had a background in storage
because Dropbox was not building storage
systems what they were building was a
new way to share and access your
information so don't be intimidated by
your lack of knowledge again in many
ways it can be a huge asset to you as
well just to quickly highlight kind of
what our mission is and then we'll come
back to kind of the the why and the how
this is how we think about our identity
today it's to go take all of that
unnecessary pain all of that difficulty
that a small business owner has to go
through and remove it right I mean these
are folks that have been on their own
for a long time no one's told them to go
start a business if any of you go start
your own businesses too it's really a
labor of love and it's not it's not just
done to go create you know huge
businesses at IPO oftentimes its
business owners that are paying for
their family covering their cost of
living and we want to remove that pain a
third of companies should not be getting
fined every year for incorrectly doing
their payroll taxes the second is to
really celebrate this human aspect of
what it means to work in Silicon Valley
we talk a lot about one in your mat work
to matter wanting to have impact with
what you do we really believe that same
message applies to flower shops bakeries
cafes churches spread across the country
and one of our goals is to bring that
ability to those businesses and then the
third one is all about the employee this
is a again when you think about
different trends in society people now
work in many companies throughout their
life and so the ability to help people
save better plan for retirement better
is a key part of our mission as well but
to kind of dive now into the journey as
well this is a fun photo we were in ly
Combinator during the winter 2012 batch
living in a house not too far from here
and whenever you start a company it's a
pretty intense time you're spending a
lot of hours together my commute was
walking up stairs which was pretty
phenomenal
today it's about a half block walk which
isn't too bad either but one funny
anecdote to share during that time Eddy
actually was living in the city two
hours of commuting every day doesn't
make too much sense so we rented him our
closet for $350 a month
and to be clear to it it had a
queen-size bed in the had a skylight
probably would rent for like three
thousand dollars a month in San
Francisco these days given rent prices
but again it kind of reinforces that
message that it's it's about shared
values and really being excited to spend
that amount of time together because it
is a very intense experience to build a
company in the same vein one thing I
also love to talk about is is kind of
the approach to fundraising for us
fundraising has never been about capital
now it's about people and if you think
about it from that perspective you can
almost apply the same lens you do to
fundraising as you do to hiring right so
for us when we hire someone it's about
their values their motivation and their
skill set when we fundraise it's the
same idea this person is now going to
become a part of your community they're
going to be an ambassador for your
business they're going to represent you
in an external context and so for us we
think about it as very analogous and
these are again some amazing folks that
we're proud to have involved these folks
didn't invest because of the desire to
simply you know make a 10x 50x hundred X
return on their investment they invested
because they really cared about the
mission and this is one thing that makes
Silicon Valley really special all of you
are a part of this community it's not a
zero-sum game you know that's what makes
in my opinion Silicon Valley really tick
this idea that there is a camaraderie
amongst entrepreneurs where you want to
help each other out and if you care
about the mission you share values with
the founder then by all means you want
to support that individual so you know
business is doing well we can gloss over
this we're proud to be serving many many
companies we have a lot more work to do
I mean any success that we've had thus
far is due to the team we've built and
ultimately we're never done I mean
that's I think one of the key lessons
and startup something I tell my team
pretty often is that we can always get
better right I think if you if you're
part of a growing company we're about 75
employees today we'll be a couple
hundred by the end of the year you know
there's an easy pattern to kind of get
into where you want to solve a problem
fix it be done with it and then you
never come back to it in the magic of a
startup and also sometimes the
frustration is that you can solve a
problem have a great conversation fit
that issue and then three days later
five people joined the company and they
weren't there for that so now they have
to go figure out what's going on again
from day one and so that ability to
repeat and actually look forward to
repeating these discussions and know
that every time you can get better has
been a key part of our growth thus far
so I kind of mentioned values a few
times this is a topic I really love
talking about and I I was at a panel
recently where someone said you talk
more about values than any founder
they've met and I'm proud to be called a
values founder if that's what I'm known
as you're never gonna see our values on
our wall these are just a couple of them
you're never gonna see them print it out
on placards values are who you are right
you don't have personal values
professional values it's really what you
stand for and again there's no black and
white answer here there's no right or
wrong value but if you're building a
team or building an organization you
want to understand your identity and
then it mostly impacts hiring it impacts
the way that you decide to add people to
your team otherwise you can become very
very split in terms of what your mission
is so just to walk through these three
and by all means if these resonate with
you feel free to use them make them a
part of whatever mission you're on one
of our core values is ownership
mentality and for us this really means
two things
again in Silicon Valley every startup
gives equity to their employees but I
think a lot of folks overlook the second
impact of giving equity because it
definitely aligns for economic outcomes
that's fair but the other impact is that
everyone in a start-up is an owner of
the business literally right and no one
should be treated like an employee so as
a management team you have to think
about how to go empower folks as owners
where no one's there just to accomplish
a single task and this one really
mattered a lot to me when I was at Intel
and I had a great time within cell but I
remember one anecdote where during that
summer I wanted to work on a project no
one was working on it needed to get done
and I volunteered to do it and someone
told me don't don't do it it's not your
job to do it and that thought really
stuck with me write it how does that
make sense how does that work how does a
company develop that mindset and this to
us is basically the anticip at write
it's how do you empower people to not
just come in and do one job or do one
specific task but to be there to go come
a couple
this common mission and then do whatever
they can to make that a reality the
second one is how I started again I
think you know one opinion I have on
society is I think we're all moving
towards a much much faster cadence in
terms of instant gratification from
whatever we do whether it's in media or
politics or stocks but building things
that are really great that have a big
impact on the world
take time and if you do have that choice
or that goal to go build something for
the long term then it's really important
to know what that means day to day in
our case it means how we hire means how
we fundraise a bunch of different
lessons so again there's nothing wrong
with wanting to build a company for two
years and then planning to sell it but
if your goal is to go build it for the
long term and make that a core part of
your DNA otherwise you can have a
misalignment within your team and then
the last one is really connected to the
first transparency again there's many
different ways to run meetings in a
business you know in our case every two
weeks we have all hands where literally
we walked through financials performance
metrics lessons learned I share things
that I've done wrong if I've made a
mistake and I own that in terms of ways
that we can improve as an organization
and again it sets a great example to
others in terms of now trusting your
team right if you're gonna be an owner
in a business you should be given the
information to think like an owner
otherwise a lot of companies get caught
up in this privacy secrecy type thing
where it almost turns into a distrust of
thing where you don't trust someone with
the information that they want because
you're afraid what they might do with it
I'd rather just hire people that we
trust from day one and then empower them
to be owners in the business another
topic I get asked a lot about is you
know how does the role of CEO evolve or
change what does it mean to be a CEO and
this is a question I ask myself a lot
when I was at Intel as well where the
CEO of Intel literally had I think at
that point there were 70,000 employees
and I wondered how does a how does a
person leading a 70,000 person company
know how to spend his or her time right
you could literally have like an hour
free and and call a head of state or
call a journalist or hire someone or do
all these different tasks how does I'm
not just overload your synapses an
answer is you know in some ways it's
it's all about delegation right it's
about firing yourself from as many jobs
as you can that's a path I've been on
since early days of the company but what
that leaves is kind of where I am
focused these are the three things that
I've concluded are really my long-term
responsibilities as a leader in a rowing
company the first is really making sure
we've set good direction and strategy
for the business right everyone's
looking to me to help facilitate but
then ultimately drive what matters right
where are we focused why are we making
this bet why is this the direction
that's best for the company and that's
something that ultimately I have to be
responsible for the second is how do we
organize how do we communicate how many
meetings do we have when do we have
meetings why should we have meetings and
then also how do we hire right which
role should we create which team should
we create and what responsibilities is
to be give to those individuals and then
the third one is again really personal
it's it's the chance to lead by example
it's basically my actions being whatever
one reads into and most of that
manifests in the context of hiring where
I spend now 50 percent of my time
interviewing people all right that kind
of might seem crazy to hear that but
that's the way it's been for two years
now and that's probably the way it'll be
for the next five or ten years and so
interviewing is a really important skill
if you guys have any questions you can
come talk to me after but the ability to
interview I think is something that
everyone should build as a skill set
when I was at Zazzle as a first job out
of school I was a PM but I also
volunteered to run all of our Stanford
college recruiting um it's just like a
muscle you have to iterate and get
better it is through practice and
interviewing again you can always get
better so you know kind of to get closer
to wrapping I um just wanted to
highlight I think it's an incredible
time to be in technology and startups I
listed out some businesses here but
really the main message is there's a lot
of problems out there now and a business
exists to solve a problem so as long as
there are problems there are
opportunities for new businesses to be
created and so you know my encouragement
to you is to find a problem that really
matters to you something you care about
something that you really believe should
be solved and that you know really again
affects you that it's still persisting
in that way the same way that for us
realizing that it was a third of
companies getting fined and in all these
businesses being run as
if it was a transactional system versus
a business being about people and
community but that's what spoke to us if
you find something that speaks to you
there's a lot of problems out there
waiting to be solved and that's the
magic of entrepreneurship is this idea
of wanting to take the impossible and
make it real and against all odds with a
team that shares a value system and is
on this mission kind of say we can do it
say we can do something that everyone
says we can't do
and so again Stanford is a big part of
that many of you are already a part of
that community but it's really inspiring
to me to see all these examples around
us and again all the cool ideas and
projects will come in the future so to
kind of wrap on these three lessons kind
of in a summary format number one
introspection these are kind of the
three I would love to make sure you
remember make sure you set aside that
time maybe in school it doesn't seem
like you need it because of the quarters
or semesters but definitely after school
create some structure that makes you
take a step back detach from the
day-to-day in our company we care so
much about this that on everyone's
one-year anniversary we give them a free
plane ticket anywhere in the world and
they have to use it by their second year
so we basically forced them to leave and
that's a way for us to get them to go
again leave detach take a step back and
really think about what they're doing
what they care about and they come back
a healthier person to come back a
healthier teammate now you can do that
on a smaller scale for me Sunday
afternoons and when I go to the gym or
really my places of introspection where
I try to detach from email detach from
slack or all the different projects I'm
working on and just kind of again think
more broadly about what's working what's
not working how am i spending my time
number two is again when you decide to
join your first company out of school
one way to think about it is not this
huge complex framework on all these
different optimizations but rather
decide who you want to become like right
when you spend time with them when your
ear viewing interviewing isn't just
about them learning about you it's
reciprocal you're learning about them
right and that's your privilege that's
your right to basically ask them
questions understand what they stand for
you know it's not just about asking for
the job what am I going to do who's my
boss but ask things like you know why do
you do this and why does this matter to
you and what is your motivation
and that kind of sometimes channel minor
to Ural I just ask why over and over
again right just why and somebody and
Susan sa why you kind of really give
back to the core of what drives someone
and if you're gonna join a company you
really want to understand what drives
the person you're joining because you're
going to become more like them whether
you want to or not and then the third
one which probably comes across and how
I talk about what I'm doing um if you're
starting a business
imagine the ten thousandth time you're
going to be talking about it and think
about if you'll be just as excited and
just as passionate as the first time
because by the 10,000th time you
definitely can't fake it and that was
what drove me my last business to want
to sell it and with this business this
is probably my five hundred thousandth
time describing our missions EP every
time is a privilege every time is a
chance to share with someone something I
believe in and care about and ask
yourself if your mission-driven if that
will exist because you can't again
artificially create that it has to be
there or not so in closing I want to
actually read this quote um to everyone
it's a little bit long but I think it's
very relevant this is a quote from Steve
Jobs and I think it's a great way to
kind of drive home this message life can
be much broader once you discover one
simple fact and that is everything
around you that you call life was made
up by people that were no smarter than
you and you can change it you can
influence it you can build your own
things that other people can use that's
maybe the most important thing it's to
shake off this erroneous notion that
life is there and you're just gonna live
in it versus embrace it change it
improve it make your mark upon it and I
think again Steve Jobs puts everything
perfectly and so rather than me trying
to paraphrase I thought it'd be better
to read it to you but that is the magic
of entrepreneurship right that's the
privilege we have and being a part of
this community is the chance to go kind
of have these bold ideas and against all
odds say hey we're going to go make that
a reality and so if you guys have any
questions for me I'm happy to answer
them grew up in San Francisco please
come visit if I can be helpful to you
please let me know
so Q&A yeah so you talk about your
tricks of interviewing but those of us
who do it a lot it would be super great
to get some of your secret secret in
science so the questions are about
interviewing so most of my interviews
I'm now usually the last person in the
interview process because there's a lot
of other folks involved before that so
my interviews are primarily focused not
on skill set but on values and
motivation so the way I usually love to
have that discussion I mean the main tip
is that Y which is whenever someone
answer is it's easy to see them get into
a pattern of listing out accomplishments
or skill sets ask why ask if they made a
life change why they made that change
and so I always usually phrase the
question to me life is about chapters I
love reading so I call them chapters my
colleague loves baseball he calls them
innings but I ask you know for these
different chapters you've been through
why did you make that transition what
were you looking for what was different
what was working what wasn't working and
then for this next chapter you're
envisioning what do you want what are
you looking for now because the whole
goal of the interview is not to have me
grill them or them to grill me it's to
understand if there's an alignment right
the whole point is just to get to know
each other better understand your values
motivation and skillset and then figure
out hey there is a match here in terms
of what we need and what we want and
what you are interested in doing and
providing and so that's one of the ways
that I get to that answer any more
questions like the payroll is different
in each state how do you approach like a
new state with the new set of
regulations where you know maybe it just
doesn't work in one state yeah yeah
parallels are very complex I joke about
it you know we we started two years ago
we launched two years ago we've been
live for three years we went kind of
public access two years ago payroll is
never in beta and ever in pilot so you
never had a period of trial and it has
to work right from day one
but we started only in California and
today we're in 40 states we'll be in all
50 in the next three months every state
is actually more like a country so I
kind of joke that we've launched
forty countries now because of the way
that US was created States set their own
policies around tax around compliance
around reports so that's much of our I
would say secret sauce is the ability to
take all of that complexity all of that
paperwork you know business is not made
better by writing their name in a better
font right it they just have to write
their name and now we have to do that
for them automatically so they can focus
more on the people side of their
business now but it is a complex
technical task
yeah I think absolutely the question was
about any sacrifices or trade-offs have
had to make in the context of our
mission there's trade-offs all the time
and it basically Tamiya ties to
prioritization I mean the biggest puzzle
in the business and I get that asked
that question a lot too is not what are
all the cool things we could do it's
what should we do now right because if
you're in a business it doesn't have a
lot to do you're probably not in a very
interesting business so I just assume we
have a million things to do at all times
forever and so then the puzzle is you
know what we do next will we do after
that so for us the value system on
long-term thinking is why we launched
only in California it's also why we
didn't rush launching other states where
we would be we could have been
nationwide with about a partial solution
where you have to do your compliance
yourself but we do the payments for you
and we knew that we wanted to be
comprehensive and develop a brand that
said you can trust us with every detail
so we basically took two years that
could have taken three months to be
nationwide because we want to build a
business for the long term so every
value I think again it drives the
behavior where you want to see if you're
authentic to it and it's not black and
white that's what I one of the trickiest
parts of strategy is that
you know if there's black and white
decisions that's almost ethical right
and that's pretty clear it's like the
right way to treat someone the right way
to hire the right way to empower someone
the tricky part of strategy is you have
these two extremes and then you have
where you want to be and the way I think
about it is you want to set a goal we
want to be here in terms of our target
and then you want to hold yourself
accountable to it so the key is the
accountability piece right if you set a
goal of hey we're gonna be more focused
on growth this quarter versus more
focused on architecture then make sure
that you know where you want to be in
the
process and then hold yourself
accountable to it people who've really
influenced the way you think about
starting companies yeah so the question
was talking about role models and kind
of who I admire who I look up to we feel
privileged a lot of the folks I look up
to are now investors and ZP so rainy
comas are who actually I met through
Stanford in a class he taught before he
joined kleiner perkins it's one of our
investors he's been a personal mentor
for 10 years if you haven't read one of
his books the monk in the riddle it's a
great book on living a Purpose Driven
Life so he's someone that I'm proud to
have involved in the community and then
from an operator standpoint Jeremy
Stoppelman is also someone that has
always been inspiring to me again a
really interesting story in terms of how
they started Yelp which I can get to
later if you want but I encourage you to
look through the investor list
I guess one message I have them on
mentorship I think sometimes people
confuse it with wanting to create this
kind of hierarchical structured like
here's my once a quarter meeting or a
set of meetings I want to have with
people mentorship or gaining advice can
happen in many ways it can happen
through reading a quote it can happen
through watching a video it can happen
through absolutely face-to-face
interactions you know my mentors are my
parents as well in terms of the example
they've set to me and the kind of
passion they had for creating a whole
new life in this new place that enabled
me to go do what I want to do so I would
just say it's not about collecting like
famous names or collecting you know
people that you can add to your resume
it really is about the interaction you
have with that individual yeah
yeah definitely so the question was
about introspection and kind of how that
journey has evolved for me I mean it's
still evolving I mean for me meditation
is a key ingredients of that in terms of
detaching from the frenetic nature of
the day-to-day and just creating almost
a more peaceful a moment in my day to go
think about those types of questions
but I don't have a rigid structure it's
not like I have four questions I ask
myself and then you know see how I map
and give myself a grade it's mostly tied
to kind of I would say two buckets one
is have I spent the time the way I
wanted to spend my time and again that
might seem easy to say but you actually
have to collect data to get that sense
right you can say hey this week I want
to spend half my time on recruiting and
then or I want to spend you know 10
percent of my time exercising and then
it actually takes a little bit of
homework to figure out hey I actually
spend 2 percent of my time exercising
and 70 percent of my time recruiting
what's wrong right how do I calibrate
maybe I should stop doing this start
doing that delegate this give this to
someone else so that's one key part of
it it's kind of the time allocation and
seeing if I'm doing what I want to do
otherwise you just become reactive to
the environment you're in the second one
is is more just call it like plentiful
but it's just me thinking and dreaming a
bit about like what the future looks
like and you know different things that
could exist either in my personal life
professional life we're kind of trying
to push the envelope and that you know
again is you could call that creativity
I think Tina obviously is very
passionate on this topic that's an
interesting part of business building so
much of a business is analytical and
framework driven and data centric and we
have metrics on growth and revenue rates
and hiring ramps but then so much of
business building is this emotional
quality of like people and people are
not objects or metrics people are you
know unique in their own way and there's
that's the whole point of hiring great
people let's go right here the
development wish to create an own
business what is something that you had
from a very young age or did it develop
during your time at Stanford yeah so the
question was about my desire to create a
business on
I guess the way I would phrase it I've
never had a desire to create a business
you know what I realized
and definitely wasn't Stanford because
before that I was just more curious
right I was bothered by an efficiency I
was curious to learn new things I felt
really good to help other people and I
was in Boy Scouts I'm an Eagle Scout we
did a lot of work that was service
centric visiting my mother's homeland
which is Bolivia a lot of opportunity to
go contribute back that always felt good
but those are just building blocks right
Stanford gave me more of a framework on
this thing called high tech you know
venture formation right and the idea of
how to use technology with business in a
capitalist society to go solve
meaningful problems but even after that
and my motivation is not to build a
business it's to go solve a problem
right and that's kind of how we think
about hiring as well is that we exist as
a company to go solve a problem and by
the way they were doing that is we're
creating a company and as a name it's
for-profit it's registered in Delaware
you know we have profit targets revenue
targets I mean that's still all there
but the driver is solving a problem this
is all just a byproduct and so you know
if you remember my story the first
startup I started we didn't have a lot
of that introspection in place it just
was reactive to just this part of it and
as a result we didn't really know where
we were going over time right he just
was working financially but then
something was missing it was after that
where I had that time for introspection
that it really crystallized to me on
what would make me happy which is always
starting with the problem so that took
you know I guess I was 28 29 when that
realization happened hopefully my advice
to you that's that happen earlier on in
your life yeah yeah I think on a
business-related question like that
I'll just chat with you after I want to
try to focus on giving some advice to
students but happy to answer that
afterwards yeah and also said there are
certain issues investors yes your
company customer support of course yeah
do you think it will be the same success
we've had if you wouldn't study here
yeah yeah so the question was related to
kind of how Stanford impacted the path
we've been on and how much has helped
that so to be clear going to Stanford is
absolutely a plus if it was a negative I
would tell you all that but no it's a
massive plus but I would put it in the
same bucket of look it's not a
prerequisite to building a business I
mean there's many entrepreneurs many of
my teammates that joined that went to
various universities didn't go to
university so I would put it into the
bucket of luck there's a lot of ways
that people or programs or skill set can
help but one of the beautiful aspects of
a startup is that all of that goes away
when you're just three people sitting in
a house trying to go build something and
decide where you should be spending your
time all that matters is the way you
spend your time and so whatever you
don't know I mean I think Stanford gives
you some frameworks it again gives you
this incredible community of people that
can help you which you should all stay
in touch with each other because
wonderful people go on and do wonderful
things but I really think no matter what
your background is that's what makes
Silicon Valley special is that if you
don't know something you can go learn it
I mean I can talk now a lot about
leadership and product and sales and
marketing I didn't take a lot of courses
in those subjects I went and did it and
then I'm the type of person that when I
was doing something I wanted to do it
well and so you can kind of think about
it from that framework if you want to
learn how to do something and you're
someone that you believe really wants to
do it well just make yourself do it and
there's a pretty good bet you're not
going to do it poorly I'm you're gonna
try to do whatever you can to do it well
and in that process you're gonna learn a
ton about how to do that thing now if
that helps yeah this said that what we
do is not important but we would do it
is and what do you think about it and
how was yes the question was around kind
of team and it's not just what we do
it's could we do it with so I obviously
really really agree with that message
you know the way I described it in our
business is it's not just about
accomplishing a goal it's about being
proud of how we accomplished that goal
and the way you accomplish your goal is
based on people all right it's
day-to-day interactions the team the
people that we contribute to that add to
our community
and so I think again there's many ways
to build a business but if you do adhere
to this philosophy and wanting to be
proud of the journey versus just
celebrate the destination then you can
never go wrong by overly focusing on
people again it's the biggest enabler of
success or failure yes skill sets when
you're starting yeah so the question was
around kind of my coming on so many EE
folks in the company and was there a
downside of that so I think I mean the
broader question is really how similar
or different should we be and I think
it's really important to clarify value
system is is a philosophy right in again
we don't have the perfect value system
we just have one that we believe is
right for us skill sets personality
biases the variety of ways that make us
all very different and unique really
important to have as much diversity
there as possible so I think from a EE
standpoint we all had a bias towards a
very analytical way of thinking now in
the context of our products in our
business that actually is a prerequisite
because our big insight early on was the
ability to go out and mate this and then
make it totally more humane I guess is
the way to put it but to be clear we
only have about five or six people now
out of 75 that are EE so is more of a
coincidence in terms of our early hiring
yeah good probably going being three
people in the house to create awareness
about your products and how do you go
from one state of thirty states yeah how
do people become aware that your system
is just yeah so I think the question was
around kind of marketing and awareness
building in particular when you're just
three people in a house how do you get
usage so I think again it depends on
your product if your consumer product it
could be as simple as listing in the app
store if your b2b product it's a very
different go to market I guess my
message on the b2b side is get out of
the house I mean literally like if you
want to have 10 customers go find those
10 customers and even before you build
your product go talk to them and say hey
I'm thinking of building this here's
what it will look like even be a
scribble or a list of bullet
and say hey if if this exists would you
want it right and if you get a lot of
people this said yes yes that would be
magical right that would be amazing I
would love that and then you go build it
and say hey here I build what you just
we're running it's here try it then you
have users you have customers right so
that would be the starting point is
don't think that it's just through a
blog post or a website or or ads we
didn't do any advertising for the first
year and a half of the company it was
purely organic driven by very high NPS
great customer satisfaction again
building a product that actually works a
lot of companies rushed too fast to paid
a position spending money on Google and
such nothing wrong with that but if you
do that too early on you don't know if
you've actually solved the problem
you're just driving a lot of users
through in an unnatural not
cost-effective way one more question
incredibly thoughtful about everything
one of the things that are keeping you
awake at night now hmm
well right now I'm in the middle of
planning my my wedding so they're not my
mind quite a bit but beyond that I think
one way to also answer that question I
get asked what keeps you up at night I
sleep great that doesn't mean that we
have a lot to do there's not a lot of
problems to solve is not a lot of work
to get done but I think that's actually
a really important note to make there's
a certain culture in Silicon Valley that
celebrates heroics and you know the you
stayed up all night great job and trust
me I've done that in the past quite a
bit but I was saying in the company that
I think really drives this message home
you know heroism doesn't scale heroes
become martyrs and if you want to build
an enduring business that scales many
many years or decades into the future
you have to build a way to grow their
ties to distributing responsibilities
empowering others to be owners so when I
think about what keeps me up at night
although I sleep well it's um it's one
of the main puzzles in our business and
in our case its focus its are we
spending our time on the right things
right are we investing our resources and
the right projects and then kind of
compared to that as well it's even that
we're growing very quickly you know
we're gonna be adding you know 150
people to the company this year going
from the 75 to over you know to 200
people are we maintaining the culture
that makes us special are we May
containing the quality of service that
has built our success thus far and that
ties to a lot of internal things most of
my time right now when I talk to
investors or talk to the team is spent
thinking about organization thinking
about the way we communicate the way we
hire on the way we celebrate those first
days in the company and all the
traditions associated with that great
join me in thanking Josh for this
amazing
you